- Après avoir libéré l'oiseau
bleu de Twitter, Elon Musk
va-t-il enchaîner les
utilisateurs du réseau
pour rentabiliser son achat
de 44 milliards de dollars?
YAN CIMON, professeur, Faculté
sciences administration, ULaval
- Monsieur Musk a parlé
par exemple, de son amour
d'un éventuel modèle basé
sur des abonnements, en allant
même jusqu'à se prononcer sur
un montant d'une vingtaine de
dollars par mois pour certains
utilisateurs vérifiés. Et donc,
ça voudrait dire qu'il cherche
activement des sources
pour monétiser son achat.
- Il a également sondé
ses abonnés sur le retour
d'anciennes fonctionnalités
comme Vine, ou même la création
de nouvelles. Autant de ballons
d'essai.
- En ce moment, il est en mode
idéation et bon, vous voyez
aussi qu'il a été très actif
sur le plan de la gouvernance.
Puisque non seulement
il a remercié certains cadres
supérieurs clés, mais il aussi
choisi de se séparer du conseil
d'administration actuel.
- Il devient donc le seul
administrateur de son entreprise
et annonce dès son acquisition,
la création d'un conseil
de modération de contenu.
Il affirme du même élan,
que toutes les opinions
pourront s'exprimer.
- La vision de la liberté
d'expression d M M Musk est très
libertarienne et donc M. Musk,
par exemple, s'est déjà prononcé
contre le bannissement à vie
de sa plateforme et il semble
sensible à des voix de droite,
qui plaident pour le retour
de personnages controversés
sur la plateforme.
- La porte du réseau est
désormais ouverte à des
personnes aux propos très
polarisants. La Ligue anti
diffamation, un organisme
américain, a noté une
recrudescence des messages
haineux sur Twitter.
- C'est un peu dommage,
parce que les utilisateurs
qui souhaintntnt avoir de la
popularité pour de la popularité
ou qui auront des propos qui
seront dison, très tranchés,
auront peut-être tendance
à utiliser cet outil-là.
Mais malheureusement, ce que
ça fait, c'est que ça va rendre
l'aspect grand public de
c c chose beaucoup moins
intéressant.
- Pour l'instant, la vision
d'Elon Musk pour son nouveau
réseau ne se précise pas.
Beaucoup de questions demeurent
en suspens, ce réseau social
va-t-il basculer vers un réseau
asocial? La ligne est bien
mince.
Ici Yasmine Khayat,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.